are you doing today sir
i'm doing great i'm i'm just hanging out
in cloudy vancouver uh on a day off and
uh trying to remember as much as i can
about the green night which i haven't
seen since october
i was going to say i think you're not
your mind has been preoccupied
just a little bit just just a smidge uh
so i have a few fun questions before
first of all congratulations on the
movie uh i cannot wait to see it again
nothing but positive things to say um
i'm really happy
you made this um and also we're you know
making movies
but um uh who took home the crown from
set and who do i need to bribe to get it
oh that's a great question i think it's
still in storage
uh with all the rest of our props uh
in the off chance that we had to do
research which obviously now that uh
that boat has sailed
um and so i think
i think it's somewhere in chicago at the
moment and a warehouse
and i've i've got very few props i
brought home from the movie
uh and i want to get an axe i want to
get the crown
i need i need a few more things for my
collection
a hundred percent um is it true that you
made
the the the round table um
the c uh purely because of your love of
criterion and your hope that this will
eventually get
a criterion release let's just let that
legend live
because uh i think that is as good a
reason to make that table look the way
it does as any
uh i read and again could be wrong that
you had found your willow action figures
and then shortly thereafter wrote the
script for this was that true
that's true i doing something in my
closet found a box of old childhood
possessions that contained all of my
willow action figures and was just
setting them up i was just like making a
made a little uh a little diorama of
them in my backyard
and thought to myself it'd be fun to
make a movie about a
night on a quest as i was placing my
little major mad martign
on his miniature horse and
and that begat this movie um i've since
put all my willow toys on a
place of honor on my shelf in my home
office um where they belong
and uh i
also bought the ebora swiss off ebay
finally because i was like i need that
dragon i need it
um oh if if disney had asked you to do
the willow
uh disney plus series would you have had
a tough time saying no
yeah it would have been a really tough
time saying no i i would i would have
you know i i don't dahlian in episodic
stuff too much because my heart belongs
to movies but that's one world where i
would have just
really wanted to uh you know spend some
time
and i'm i feel like i'm like sort of
like you know i've got like a secondhand
connection because a lot of the green
nightcast went on to act in that so
i'll see some familiar faces in it i
love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
you know hearing stories that maybe are
um you know not easy to hear
uh what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of the
green knight
um i don't know if it's a surprise but
it's interesting which is that i was
like deathly ill for half of the
production
and my memories of the entire shoot were
just pain
so that the fact that i actually was
able to actually
finish making the movie uh especially
now like
if we were to if i were to get as sick
as i did on this movie
now i would have not been allowed on set
because for obvious reasons
you know with copic protocol um i came
down with some horrible flu and there
were two days
joel edgerton's first day two days on
set i couldn't talk i had no
voice and had to just communicate with
handwritten notes
um so that isn't one bit of trivia that
is not
it's funny now in retrospect but at the
time it was i didn't know if i was going
to make it out of this movie alive
how long did it take for you to recover
um without getting
too detailed i had surgery upon my first
ever surgery first time going under
as soon as we wrapped i just was like i
was like i may not survive this movie or
if i if i can just make it
if i can make it to the final day of
production uh
then at least we'll have all the fridge
in the can someone can put it together
and uh
and so we rap and then i went home and
went to the doctor and had surgery and
and
was fine thankfully but um there were
definitely a point where i was like this
might be the last thing i ever make so
i've got to just like
pull pull together and and and at least
get all the footage in the can
i can't imagine what your wife was
saying to you while you were shooting
and how angry i didn't know anything i
didn't tell anybody and no one knew
so i was just like i was like this i was
like all signs point to this being very
serious
i'm going to just uh you know we got you
know
20 days left i'm just gonna just push
through and
and not raise any you know cause any
waves
and then when i finally told my wife
post surgery uh she just laughed
it was an odd moment where i was like i
was like i feel weird that you're
laughing about this right now
but she did um uh one of the things is
that uh
this movie has a lot going on in it um
there's a lot for people to enjoy
and take away from um what are you
really excited for people to see
in the film i'm excited for them to see
all of it you know
like there's a lot of stuff in there and
hard to pick one thing you know i went
for a long period of like
in an editorial process of not liking
the movie which happens with all my
movies
you're learning what it is you made when
you're editing and with this one it took
me a long time to like
embrace what it was that i made and to
really separate the
difficulty of production from the
finished film and
and so now i i look at the movie almost
with an objective
especially because i've had this long
delay in getting it out into the world
i've got like an objectivity to it
and i'm excited to see what people
discover in it
because some just to a certain extent
i know what's in the movie i know what i
put in there but i don't know
what people will pick up on and i've
i've talked to some folks who have seen
it
and and the the and i've been
pleasantly surprised at all the things
that i now realize were in fact
intentional like people like well that
one thing you did
inference you made that reference that
that theme that gets drawn out in this
scene or that scene i was like
oh yeah that was something i was
thinking about two years ago when we
were shooting this it wasn't
it wasn't an accident there was
intention behind this movie and i'm so
grateful that people are now getting the
chance to like see those intentions
realized
but um i hope i hope people find that
it's an adventure
i mean that's my my what i wanted to do
i want to make an adventure movie i want
to make a quest film and it's not
a traditional adventure movie it's
certainly not game of thrones or lord of
the rings but
it shares some dna with those things and
i and i hope that people
the audiences appreciate and enjoy this
sort of off-kilter quest
that we we've created and i hope i hope
also that it inspires people to go back
and read the original poem which is a
really
uh a really wonderful piece of
literature that i
just even in in preparing to talk about
the movie i've been rereading it and
it's just so
it's a piece of it's a piece of uh
literature that just keeps on giving
you can just keep finding things in
there that are just so beautiful
beautifully written and it's and it's so
dense i mean it's been
analyzed for almost the better part of a
millennium at this point
and with good reason and i think we've
we've scratched the surface of what that
text contains with this movie
and i hope that in scratching the
surface we've opened a door for people
to go discover it
yeah it's pretty amazing that the poem
is
what's 600 and something years old that
it was written that long ago
and it's still amazing it's just it's
yeah it's incredible
as as archaic as it is it's also very
modern like you read it and it feels
like
something that you know could have been
written aside from the language
being written in middle english of
course it's on a narrative level feels
very very modern all the same you know
uh
narrative structures that we now enjoy
as as purveyors of media like
all were in play in the 14th century
including the giant third act exposition
dump that uh morgan lafaye gives
in the phone uh
you mentioned a little bit about the
editing um i'm obsessed with the editing
process because
it is the final rewrite and the whole
movie comes together in the editing room
uh did you have a much longer cut of the
film
can you sort of talk about the
challenges that you encountered
definitely
the the script was maybe 85 pages 80 85
it was very short
and the first cut which was true to that
script
was like 2 hours and 45 minutes and it
was
it was just off balance it didn't quite
it lurched around in a way that i didn't
want the film to
to do and so i i i spent a lot of time
in the edit like just trying to
iron it out and make the rhythm of it
flow naturally and organically
and that involved cutting a lot of
material um as anyone who's read the
poem will know the sequence of the lord
and ladies castle
is quite extensive and we had to cut a
lot of material we all we originally had
a much longer version of that
that was truer perhaps to the text but
it just
caused the film to be more unwieldy than
it needed to be
and it really you know didn't need
it didn't need what the poem needed and
so
i i let a lot of material go i reshaped
a lot of material
we did every movie i do i always
schedule some pickups because you always
find time you always find things you
wish you had
so we did a few days of pickups to sort
of patch up some of the holes that were
left
uh by those by the excision of from the
excision of those scenes
and and then i just spent a lot of time
just ironing and ironing it all out
you know the opening sequence with the
green knight in the script that's
probably five pages but the first cut of
that was 40 minutes long
and and it was too long you know it was
like and so just finding a way to just
sort of like
you know get the pace up pick the pace
up get the green knight into the great
hall sooner
build you know gawan's uh making sure
god was a constant presence throughout
that sequence and
watching him make his decision you know
all those things took a lot more work
than i was expecting
and the editorial process was one that
was far more fraught than i used to
because
i felt so much responsibility to the
source material i wanted to make sure i
was doing it as much just as i possibly
could
as a huge fan of pete's dragon uh i mean
and everyone on collider loves pete's
dragon um
we are all so curious about peter pan
and wendy and your
take on the material what excited you to
make it and maybe you know how is it
different than the other peter pans
that have come before personally
speaking it's my favorite thing i've
ever made
which i wasn't expecting going into it
but it is it's i'm
i've never been as in love with a movie
as i am with this one and we're on
day we just finished day 91 of principle
of shooting we've got a couple weeks
left to go
and i am i just love this movie and it's
the most
personal thing i've ever made it's the
most i don't know i just love everything
about it
but it is ironically the most
adult movie i've ever made and i went
into it thinking that
you know my way in was my my entryway
into this movie was that i've
got a classic case of peter pan syndrome
i don't want to grow up
who does uh and i thought that was what
was gonna appeal about to me about it
but in making it
in writing it and then now directing it
and seeing it come to life i've realized
that this is a movie about me letting go
of that
and i don't know whether that's good or
bad i don't i haven't processed yet but
it's the first movie i've made from an
adult perspective
if that makes any sense and so it's very
true to both
you know the original book and to the
elements of the disney movie that we can
adapt you know obviously there's a lot
of things about the animated film that
you're just gonna let
leave to leave to the darker side of
history but it's it's then we're not
reinventing the tail
but i hope that we are illuminating it
and making it
a movie of great import it'll be you
know it'll be
an entire generation's first peter pan
movie and that's something i don't take
lightly and i want this to be a movie
that
is is important to the the children who
see that you know
peter pan's an evergreen property it's
something that will be remade and retold
add infinitum for the rest of time this
version of it will be
you know it's my version of it it's the
version that
for the next you know 10 years will
probably be the one that kids watch for
the first time
until it gets remade again and i want uh
i
i want to make a movie that will matter
to that the kids will look back on
fondly and think that they
they got something from it that they
learned something from it that it
mattered to them
and i hope that adults will feel the
same way because me as as someone who
is just now finally feeling comfortable
with calling myself an adult
i think there's a lot of valuable
material that we've we've
pulled from the source from the text and
i'm i don't know i'm really
i've said it already i'm just in love
with this movie and i really am excited
to
to show it to people i could ask you a
million other things uh but i know you
probably have more interviews
i'm just gonna say seriously congrats on
green knight
and um obviously anything we can do on
collider to help you
please let me know oh absolutely i i
love it always love chatting with you
steve and uh i know we always like end
up with a fist bump which
we're not in person though exactly